Hồi anh khắc sống lớn trảan qua đế biển của nguồn trôi bé trai chính tuổi tại Trung Quốc.
Sư Việt Sài Xà Chio bẩy tháng tạm tại bởi biển thị trấn Sitan Tình Chit Zhang.
Theo SMP, thơ điểm đó, của vực biển phía đông Trung Quốc có sống tạo giòn lớn giò anh hưởng từ bạo đò phín đàn tiến vào gần bởh.
Thì ngành được khi lại cho thấy ra đình bốn người, gồm hăng người lớn và 2 trẻ em,
cố gắng trạc qua bởi ké sau khi tham quan một địa điểm du lịch trong lúc biển động.
Một kênh sóng lớn tánh mạnh chàn qua, số ngá ca bốn người và cuốn bé trai chỉ tuổi xuống biển mất tích.
Chính quyền địa phương cho biết đã phong toạ bởi biển và dựng hàng rau tạm thời,
nhưng nhóm người này dựng như đã phức lờ cạnh báo, tiến vào khu vực phản biển bị cấm.
Được lượng chức năng được quy đồng tìm kiếm trong 2 ngày, đông thời dài kiểu mùi người khác bị mắc kèt giò biển động.
Thì báo đò phín đổ bộ vụ biển phía đông chết Zhang Chio Chín tháng tám với sức gió 1,5% mốt kí lúc mát trên giờ,
thời tiết khắc nghiệp hơn, lượng cứ hộ chỉ có thể sự dụng kiến viến vào quan sát tới các đường cao để tiếp tục tiêm kiếm bé trai.
Đây là cân báo thứ 18 tại chú quốc trong năm nay, giữa báo về mưa 2,5% đến 4,5% mốt mùi mì li mẹ, tại một số khu vực phản biển chết Zhang,
làm tăng quyết cơ lập lột sát lợ ở các vùng lần cận như thực 2, phúc kiến.